Lowell Navi now we're in the isolation
area it's this part here on $1.00 stuff
for in the access chamber there's less
air pressure compared to the outside
this is where the staff puts on a
special medical suit you go in in pairs
the two people help dress one another
you'll never go in alone we started
training during the summer because we
felt the risk was getting higher Alma
would swell in a medical environment
biological fluids at high risk for the
wider public though all the traveler the
risk is limited during the incubation
period for 21 days after treatment we
check the health of the medical staff
every day in case there are symptoms you
go inside the patient's room and you go
out through a different door you never
go backwards we call them yesterday the
contamination of some nurses in Europe
is often due to a high rate of patient
admissions so medical facilities are
under pressure soft football strong take
a load that's like an orchestra we play
a musical school I'm the chief of
service so I coordinate the ensemble but
there's an orchestration so there are no
useless moves you shouldn't be too few
or too many this is why we need to train
there is no room for improvisation when
you receive a very contagious patient
let's shall take cotton
you